I'm actually gonna head out now
I love so many of you in so many ways
jarick makes a shocking exit from
paradise after breaking things off with
Taoiseach I just like in the middle of
trying all that I'm not even wanna be
the drama continued to unfold as the
John Paul Jones Derrick and tisha love
triangle got even more complicated on
Monday night's episode of bachelor in
paradise jcj and Derek's fight over
tisha reignited and Haley felt led on
first
JPJ caught some heat from Haley remember
he took her on that romantic one-on-one
my patient and to explore a romantic
relationship with Derek because you
don't feel like he was being honest
about the latisha
but you didn't even tell me that you
were invitation what I told you earlier
but I didn't know you were actually like
batting Derek tried to clear the air
with JPJ once again after their major
blow-up at bi p alums chris Rondon and
crystal Nielsen's wedding last week yet
again it did not work out this is not
about tisha this is about you're making
decisions for Taoiseach now you don't
get to make things up and just very much
so Derek was attacked verbally and you
know it's unfortunate to say this but
you know JPJ was very much out of line
and very aggressive and what took place
was this happened in front of my family
my mom saw the whole thing so I knew
about this before even we saw previews
but he attacks Derek in a way where he
seems very narcissistic and a lot of
anger which really scares will probably
scared what in question viewers as to
maybe a people as far as you know the
emotional stability Keysha
ultimately broke things off with Derek
which ultimately left him no choice but
to leave paradise you're sure it's not
if you can definitively say that to me
then
et recently spoke with paradises
resident bartender Wells Adams who
weighed in on Derek's dating situation
Derek's track record as he went on the P
was on to the show with me and he got
dumped by Jojo and then he went on
bachelor in paradise for got engaged and
in fact we've got dumped again and then
now he comes on this one and he gets it
he does it I don't know how he's if
anything he's a terrible danger another
womanizer he was here absolutely if I
love absolutely to me this person and
the opposite happened for him
so it's really sad to see someone who's
so great and deserves to actually like
find someone and to be happy to see him
be so unhappy today I mean it broke my
heart
[Music]